if 6 is less than the absolute value of
x minus 3 which is less than 7 and x is
equal to 0 what is one possible value of
the absolute value of
x so let's just rewrite this first
compound inequality then we'll think
about this constraint of x being less
than zero so they're telling us that six
is less than the absolute value of x
minus three which is less than seven
so let's just think about what it means
to take the absolute value an absolute
value of an expression or of a number
could be viewed as well how far is that
number away from zero for example we've
seen this before
negative five is five away from zero 5
is 5 away from 0. so if you think about
it that way and now let's draw a number
line and visualize where would x minus 3
sit where all the possible places where
x minus 3 could sit i'm going to try to
draw a pretty big number line so we can
visualize it reasonably well
so let's say that this right over here
is zero
this is positive six
this is positive seven
positive seven and this is negative 6
negative 6 and this is negative 7.
so if x minus 3 sits in this interval
between 6 and 7 and not equaling those
because these aren't less than or equal
these are just less than signs so if x
minus 3 is in this interval between 6
and 7
so if x minus 3 is there
then the absolute value of x minus 3
squared is going to be between 6 and 7
away from 0. but the other place where x
minus 3 could be is in this interval is
in this interval between negative 6 and
negative 7 x minus 3 could also be there
because anything here if you take any
value in that interval right over there
it's absolute value it's distance from
zero it's between six and seven away
from zero notice something over
here would be so for example negative
6.2 that is between 6 and 7 away from
zero so this is the absolute value the
distance of this this distance to the
left if we're thinking about this area
and it's the distance to the right of
zero for thinking about things in this
interval
so what are the two situations well this
blues situation is just
six is less than
x minus three which is less than seven
we're essentially assuming that x minus
three is positive but then there's the
case where x minus three could be
negative and in that case we have
negative seven
negative seven is going to be less than
x minus 3
x minus 3 which is going to be less than
negative 6. so these are the two cases
and to figure out what x would be in
each of these cases we could add 3 to
all three parts of this inequality
so if you add
3 to 6 you get 9 is less than add 3 here
that's the whole point the 3 and the
negative 3 cancel out is less than x and
then
less than 7 plus 3 is 10.
so that's one possibility the other
possibility over here if you add 3 to
all the different parts of this compound
inequality negative 7 plus 3 is negative
is less than x minus 3 plus 3 is x
which is less than negative 6 plus 3 is
negative 3.
now so if this was our only constraint
this is what we would know about x that
either this is true or this is true
but then they tell us another constraint
they tell us that x is
x is less than
x is less than zero
so x can't be greater than nine so we
can rule out this case which pretty much
rules out that case and makes us focus
on this case x has to be less than 0.
so what's one possible value of the
absolute value of x well you can pick
any x in this interval between negative
3 and negative 4. you could put you
could say well okay x could be equal to
negative 3.1 you could say x is equal to
negative 3.01 you could say x is equal
to negative
3.56 you could say x is equal to
negative 3.99
all of these x's are in this interval so
one possible value well we could just
say let's just say x is equal to
negative 3.5 you take the absolute value
of x so then
the absolute value of x would be equal
to positive 3.5
and we are done